manchi no I don't think they'll be meant
to bring up a man cheeks I thought women
have to blame they keep on staying with
the man and then complaining that he
cheats every man cheats you don't like
it get rid of him if you stay with him
he continues cheating shop about it so
if um would a man cheat because you were
offering him good sex yes a man would
cheat if he wants to cheat
I've just found one that doesn't know
what you do
there's literally nothing you could do
to stop him no but I've found one that
doesn't they're the Rarity but they're
out there
so if you were like just say the
traditional good woman why did the man
cheat or what happened that's a
traditional room is going I've got
nothing to do with his dick he does what
he likes with it as a traditional woman
how can I say
the men will tell you it doesn't matter
it's not I didn't take it personal it's
not about oh they're in love with this
woman that's what it's just like as I
heard a young man say they've got a nut
to bust and they did that's it but why
would he not bust it with you like maybe
you went there at the time you could
have been at work and she was hot and
cold she was hot and available right
that's what I'm saying like like Eddie
was saying earlier sex is different for
guys than it is for girls we not all
girls some girls can just have sex but
some most girls have an emotional level
to it whereas guys can just bust a nut
to anybody
it doesn't matter
because [ __ ] happens like if he's gonna
cheat he's going to cheat there's
nothing you can do to stop and often the
guy's an achiever God don't even look as
good as these main girls are that's how
you know that's how you know a brother's
a dog when these girls is like cool if
the girl's nicer then you can kind of
validate that cool it makes sense but
more time is just she was there rat
plays racktime rat circumstances and
[ __ ] went live I'm not advocating for it
I became foreign
men need discipline the boys ever look
back and think oh you know what my
girl's actually really pretty why did I
cheat with this of course as soon as
they must have not they think that's
true
and then take you on holiday that's how
you know it's on my team you stop buying
you bear [ __ ]
that's how much he loves you that's
that's how much he loves you because as
soon as he bust that night he's like you
know what I miss my babes
it's the worst day when you realize you
have to worry about ugly girls too
you're like yeah
but like Paul said
um women don't like eight percent of men
men don't have that standard they just
they like they're like 50. around 50 of
the time yeah they would probably just
do that swiping but if they in front of
if the woman's in front of them that
goes up to 80 90.
what did you say earlier you said if the
if the guy turns the girl down for sex
he should be dead is there he the she'll
kill him yeah no I mean I wouldn't
they've got to be so wrong with the girl
because I can't see no man turning down
the womb that's why I said he must be
like a corpse
nah I don't disagree with that It's
gotta be something that's
maybe it's a fishy smell I don't know
maybe I don't know
maybe he's too pleased no no this is
where I have to come in because at cool
I believe fundamentally that men need to
learn sexual discipline yeah to to not
be a dog in doggy situation so for me
personally I took a year out of six to
learn sexual discipline just so I could
have the power to say no when the time
was right so there was times when I'm
I've got a girl in bed and we she said
look I'm gonna come over we're going to
watch a movie
before I probably would have tried to
make a move now we're genuinely just
going to watch a movie because I've
learned sexual discipline I think that's
important but not every guy
I got invited onto a date and they said
where do you want to go and I said I
want to go to the movies and because I
don't have people in front of me so I
just chose the backs the background me
not thinking now we're older people back
row I was like we're talking about what
are you doing because oh but I thought I
said listen right I will come to watch
the movie
it's about the movie I said I've got a
house there if I want to go back to but
no all this Netflix and chill no no
that's what I'm saying so sexual
discipline for a man is important to
mitigate those situations for both for
both was that with your partner no
because it was a friend it was just a
date supposed to be a date okay an
old-fashion dates like back years ago
old-fashioned 32 years ago you're trying
to check me
right I'm 54 years old no no
my son's 36 what else do you want to
know no I'm saying was this date before
you met your this partner
yes okay so this was when you were and
what if I said to you that it was a date
when I had my partner I'm just asking
okay then no I'm just asking does it
make a difference no no it should though
shouldn't it think about it you should
it should no I'm just asking no but
you're asking for a stupid reason
because it should no I'm asking because
you don't make no difference no because
you said um old people because obviously
because you said something about old
people that sounds 36 so I've got to say
that in it no no but I just thought that
you went like obviously if you went in
your even early 20s you're not old you
get what I mean yeah it's only because
you said oh as old people you know you
didn't know what the back was so I
thought 20 is not old do you get what I
mean that's what I was asking you yeah
like would it make a difference you
still not getting what I'm saying
because it should make a difference it
should make a difference while you're
asking the question basically the answer
for you shouldn't be yeah
like as old people something you know
what I'm saying is that you're missing
the point
because I'm saying to you that I'm in a
relationship and I've been on a date
you're not interested in that no because
you're saying you're a traditional woman
so I know that's not the fact I'm gonna
be a traditional woman I'm not married
I'm having sex regular is that
traditional I thought you were
traditional sorry I can't be no no no no
no no no
okay don't confuse traditional at all I
would not say that I'd say that I'm old
okay
no I'm not traditional I'm not married
how can I be traditional I'm having sex
outside of marriage how can I be
traditional okay because when you was a
traditional way means that you have sex
in a marriage and that you're married
that's traditional so don't get confused
you can behave traditional I might
behave traditional okay but I'm not
traditional sorry and I'm not a
hypocrite either no my apologies only
because obviously when you were saying
being a traditional woman is better
whatever I thought you were no no I was
asking you because of the when you said
about the modern and the tradition okay
because you stand a dance of being
traditional because you're married but
as far as I'm concerned when you're not
married when you get divorced and you
move on you're not traditional no more
that's the difference between you and me
you've got a chance to be traditional
because you've got a ring if you get
divorced now in my view you're not
traditional anymore because you're
divorced so between you and me I would
say Traditional Values doesn't make you
traditional
can you be traditional again even after
a divorce you get married again will you
then no traditional is you're a virgin
and then you get married okay that's
that's traditional if you didn't do that
you're not traditional okay I'm not
traditional I have Traditional Values as
in I prefer like old school I don't like
all you know the dating apps and stuff
like that I personally don't do them but
I wouldn't be able to say I am
traditional because I've had sex out of
wedlock I've had kids out of wedlock you
know that I am I have a very modern life
but I just deep down it's when it comes
to love and stuff like that and values
it's you know what our parents grew up
with our grandpa Foundation yeah like
you know back in the 1900s whatever
1940s 1950s before
foreign
for the
ladies actually
if a guy had everything you wanted could
you look past him stepping out from time
to time
not not another way as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible